elektroautos könnten ihren triumphzug
schon längst gefeiert haben nur eine
sache stehen dabei immer noch im weg die
begrenzte akkuleistung und damit auch
die reichweite doch ein australisches
forschungsteam will jetzt den bislang
leistungsfähigsten lithium schwefel akku
überhaupt entwickelt haben doch nicht
nur die leistung soll überragend sein
es gibt wohl noch einen weiteren
entscheidenden vorteil zum science
fiction legen täglich spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal und aktiviert
die glocke nur dann verpasst er nichts
los geht's herzlich willkommen dieser
neu entwickelte akku sollen nicht nur
besonders leistungsstark sondern auch
stabil und langlebig sein
das australische forschungsteam hat
dafür lithium schwefel batterien
verbessert und zwar durch ein neues
design der schwefel kathode denn genau
hier liegt der schwerpunkt dieser akku
art denn im laufe der zeit verändern
sich das volumen und die struktur der
kathode enorm und genau das führt zu
einer verminderten akkuleistung
problematisch ist vor allem die
skalierung denn es gilt je dicker die
kathode wird umso größer ist die
sogenannte elektroden des integration
dennoch haben die zum schwefel akkus
große vorteile sie sind im vergleich zu
den lithium-ionen-akkus die häufiger
eingesetzt werden sehr viel leichter und
außerdem auch billiger zudem lassen sie
sich umweltfreundlicher und
kostengünstiger produzieren und so
wollen fachleute weltweit die lithium
schwefel akkus unbedingt
weiterentwickeln und verbessern denn auf
ihnen ruht die große hoffnung daraus
irgendwann endlich den langersehnten
super akku zu kreieren
dann könnten auch elektroautos endlich
ihren endgültigen siegeszug feiern und
das allgemeine fortbewegungsmittel
werden wobei wir ja schon auf einem ganz
guten weg sind allerdings um sich als
echte super akkus zu etablieren dürfte
ein akku nicht mehr im laufe der zeit an
kapazität verlieren zudem müsste die
gefahr der explosion eingedämmt werden
und auch die energiedichte müsste
optimiert werden doch nicht nur bei der
weiterentwicklung von elektroautos
sondern auch in anderen bereichen würde
an solche super akku für durchbrüche
sorgen als zitat vielversprechend
bezeichnet holger althaus vom fraunhofer
institut für werkstoff und strahltechnik
diese technik erste anwendungen werden
dort gesehen wo es um geringes gewicht
geht beispielsweise in der luftfahrt das
australische forschungsteam hat sich der
grosse herausforderung angenommen wie
eben schon angesprochen ist die
mechanische
mobilität der kathode dabei die große
herausforderung wenn sie den sich durch
die ständige aufnahme und abgabe von
lithium ständig aus und zieht sich dann
wieder zusammen
die folge es entstehen micro brüche und
risse und die zelle verschleißt in hoher
geschwindigkeit möglicherweise kann
dieses problem aber durch das neue
design der schwefel kathode gelöst
werden es basiert auf einem bindemittel
namens natrium k.box methyl zellulose
also cmc wird es genannte sorgt dafür
dass schwefel und kohlenstoff an der
kathode zusammengehalten werden durch
eine neu entwickelte methode wird dieses
mittel feiner und effizienter im
kathoden material verteilt dazu heißt es
in der aktuellen studie das ermöglicht
die bildung von mechanisch starken
brücken bindung zwischen den materialien
und derzeit kathoden mit einzigartiger
architektur diese kathoden haben große
reaktions oberflächen können lade stress
vertragen und haben eine hohe
elektrische leitfähigkeit und ionen
durchlässigkeit nach angaben des
forschungsteams könnte sogar bei
dickeren schwefel schichten
leistungsdichten von mehr als 1200
milliamperestunden programm erreicht
werden und das entspricht dem dreifachen
wert der gängigen lithium ionen akkus
das zeigt ein erster test der
australischen fachleute und der
offenbarte noch mehr nämlich dass die
neuartigen akkus auch nach mehr als 2
100 ladezyklen kaum etwas an ihrer
leistung einen wüsten die kathode
erreichte so einen wirkungsgrad von 99
prozent
die expertinnen experten feiern das als
großen erfolg
ein solches niveau anhaltender kapazität
ist für schwefel kathoden dieser dicke
bislang unerreicht unseres wissens nach
ist diese kombination von exzellenter
zyklen stabilität und wirkungsgrad
einzigartig für kathoden mit so
raumschiffe gehalt das klingt doch viel
zu schön um wahr zu sein doch nicht nur
das auch die herstellung dieses neuen
batterien die seitz hat enorm viele
vorteile
demnach kann dies nicht nur
kostengünstig erfolgen sondern auch
zitat zu einer erheblichen reduzierung
von umweltgefährdenden abfällen
verhelfen das liegt daran dass für die
produktion vor allem wasser basierte
prozesse genutzt werden zudem gilt
schwefel anders als nickel und kobalt
als abfallprodukt und ist weltweit
verfügbar neue super batterie lädt in
fünf minuten ibm können
highspeed akku an anschauen also hier
anklicken und falls er es
irrtümlicherweise verpasst haben solltet
klicks zum nature unbedingt abonnieren
bis dann bleibt dran